all right so people are going to
continue filtering in for a couple of
minutes but it's actually 11 40 right
now which i think means i'm officially
allowed to start so um thanks for your
comments on here developer productivity
has taken the win in the end brilliant
all right then so this talk
is this um and i should start by
introducing myself so hi everyone thanks
for coming my name is steve and um and i
work at microsoft on the dot net team
and uh particularly been focusing for a
few years on blazer
and you are obviously
wonderful people of great wisdom and
good taste since you've chosen to come
into this talk so um i'm happy to be
spending this time with you
during this talk there's kind of two
parts to it we're going to spend the
first 40 minutes or so focusing on
blazer and uh where where we've recently
been where we're going in the future
where we might go a bit further out and
then for the last 20 minutes or so we're
going to change the focus to something a
little bit more far-fetched and from the
future and more experimental
but even though there's two separate
parts to this talk
it's all part of a single unified
timeline so you can think of this talk
as a bit of a journey through time if
you like we're going to start with
talking about what the current state of
things is for blazer developers and then
where we're going to head after that so
to get started where we are with blazer
at the moment is we've just done our net
6 release how many of you have used
blazeron.net 6 yet
oh that's like about a third of you how
many of you have used any other uh
version of blazer prior to that
yeah that's like
two-thirds of you all right so there's
still a third of you that haven't
experienced this wonderful thing just
yet um so dotnet six is the most recent
release of dot-net it came out in
november last year we do a major release
every year so that's not surprising and
we did a lot of work to improve things
for blazer in dot net six i'm going to
demonstrate some of them for you and in
particular i'm going to be focusing on
the ways that we've made blazer
able to work now with an incredibly wide
range of other technologies so that'll
be a a big emphasis as we go through
this talk the ability to use blazer with
just about anything else that you want
to use but not absolutely everything
will be on that subject so for example
the the biggest feature that we did a
lot of work on in.6 was hot reload you
probably know what that is but in case
you don't it's the ability to edit your
code and see the changes live in your
browser without having to wait for
recompiles without having to restart
your application that sort of thing i'll
give you a demo of that in a minute
um but one thing that we did do that is
about working with other technologies is
the ability if you want to to use your
blazer components whether they're
written with blazer webassembly or
blazer server inside other technologies
so if you've got an angular or a
view or a react application you want to
use blazer inside it you can now do that
i'll show you how that works
we did a feature for blazer webassembly
which is to pre-compile your.net code to
raw webassembly by code
because normally blazer in the browser
is running on the net interpreter and if
we do aot compilation we can make your
code run 10 or 20 times faster at the
cost of being bigger and taking longer
to compile but it's a good trade-off in
a lot of cases
we uh speaking of app size we made the
smallest blazer web assembly apps
smaller they used to be about 1.6
megabytes prior to.net six but you can
now strip out more stuff if you want you
can get it down to about one megabyte
which is obviously nice um we also added
the ability to work with uh code written
in other languages so if you've got some
libraries that are reading go python
rust swift anything that can run on
webassembly you can now use that
directly inside your blazer webassembly
applications there's actually loads of
other stuff that we did which i'm not
going to have time to go through one by
one and this is stuff that shipped
already so you can go and check out the
release notes on github if you want to
but i really want to show you some of
this stuff you don't want to see slides
i know you want to work with some code
because you're mostly developers so
let's do some demos of some of this
stuff we're going to need a scenario and
the scenario we're going to have
for many of the blazer demos in this
talk is a space agency a fictional space
agency called blaze orbital
and this is a company that you work for
imagine you are a developer working for
a space agency and your job is to work
within the manufacturing group so
there's various groups within this
company you work on the team that builds
and designs things like rockets and
space stations that sort of thing and
you particularly work on the
inventory management system which sounds
a bit less cool when you think about it
but hey you still work for a space
agency so you can still feel good and
look uh popular at parties so we're
going to start this application which we
imagine that you've written using blazer
webassembly and we're going to add some
functionality to it now first thing is
we have to log in because you know it's
all secure and highly locked down so the
back end servers won't talk to us if we
don't log in so we'll do that and then
this webassembly application will start
making grpc calls to a back end in order
to get some data got some stuff about
what's going on in the warehouse but we
don't really care about that for the
purposes of these examples we're going
to focus mostly on this inventory screen
over here now when i go over there you
see that it's starting to synchronize
data from the back end server
that's all coming in over grpc and it's
actually storing it in a client-side
sqlite database so we've got sqlite
compiled to webassembly in the browser
and we'll talk about how that works in a
minute but the great benefit of doing
this of having all the data locally in
the client is that you can provide a
really spectacular user experience so
even though we've got a lot of data here
we've got 100 000 items i can just
instantly scroll to any point in this
list and it just shows up straight away
we don't have to wait for responses to
come back from the server we can also do
things like querying and you can see
that that's going to update as i type we
can obviously do things like sorting and
we can do filtering and it's really nice
how this sort of thing works you can see
as i scroll it's just incredibly
responsive it's like 60 frames per
second of
querying there so you wouldn't be able
to do that if you were talking to a
server all the time so it's quite nice
that we can do these kinds of things
quite happy with it but there are some
things about this application that are
not so great for example these
ridiculous numbers over here what on
earth is this seven is that millions
billions or what are we talking dollars
pounds i don't know what's going on with
these crazy price numbers so let's fix
that using the power of hot reload
and that is something that we did a lot
of work on in.net 6 and hopefully is
going to make you more productive so
let's just see how this price number
is implemented in our code and i'm going
to go into vs and i'm going to find the
specific blazer component that is
rendered there now obviously there's way
too much code for you to read so don't
feel like you're under pressure to take
all that in at once all you really need
to notice is that we've got a grid and
the source code for that grid is inside
this reaper i'll give you a link to it
later and the way it's able to handle
such a lot of data really fast is
because it's a virtualized grid so it's
just rendering what's on the screen as
you scroll and there's various columns
in there the one that we're going to
care about just now is this one that
displays the price and you can see it's
displaying the price in cents which
explains these awful looking numbers so
let's fix that shall we let's make a
small change to the code and i'm going
to move the brow the ide down here and
i'll say okay let's say firstly we want
to display it in dollars so i'm going to
just divide by 100 like that and i'm
going to click on the save button and
because of the glory and wonder of hot
reload
just simply clicking that button should
in theory cause the browser to update
and i don't lose my scroll position my
filtering conditions or anything like
that i don't have to recompile it just
updates
now in case that was a bit subtle let's
change this a bit more let's change the
column title to put a dollar in just so
that people understand what that is so i
press save and then that is just going
to show up again in the browser without
me having to switch back maybe i want to
change the alignment to right alignment
because it's a number so again i'm going
to save that and then it's going to jump
over onto the right just like that
and finally i'd like to have some comma
separators in the middle of that so i
can write some arbitrary c sharp stuff
here let's use a number with zero
decimal places and i'll press save one
more time and now the commas are going
to appear right in the middle of that
number right there so we've managed to
make that actually make sense and we've
had a really good developer experience
as we went excuse me so we didn't have
to recompile we didn't have to switch
back to a browser it was nice and fluid
now we don't support hot reloading every
type of code change at the moment we
support more for blazer server than we
do for blazer web assembly but we are
working on closing that gap and
increasing the amount of code changes
that can be hot reloaded in the case
that you make a change that can't be hot
reloaded the system will detect that and
it will automatically reload stuff in
your browser so you still don't have to
like manually recompile but whether it's
really fast or not so fast depends on
what code changes you make
all right so that's hot reload but let's
start talking about working with other
technologies since that's something we
want to focus on a bit
let's say that we want to use some
libraries the written with other
languages that normally have got nothing
to do with net or javascript and the
scenario for this is let's go into one
of these things let's go to the personal
jetpack that sounds fun and in here
you'll see that this is meant to be a
shipping label that people can print out
and stick on stuff in a warehouse and
we're meant to have a qr code where this
gray box is
so how can we render a qr code well one
way you could do it obviously is you
could go and get a nuget package that is
implemented in.net and renders qr codes
or you can do it with javascript through
js interop if you wanted to but for the
sake of this talk let's imagine that for
whatever reason you are required to use
a library that is implemented in a
different language altogether let's say
rust now as it happens i have got a rust
implementation of a qr code renderer
over here
okay now i know a lot of you probably
are not rust developers i'm not really a
rust developer although i did manage to
piece this together and uh so just to
give you a momentary overview this is
using a third-party crate or package
called qr code and that is going to
render some data into a buffer this
array of bytes just there
and this is all exposed as a function
called generate qr code and we're going
to want to call that from our blazer
code which is running on webassembly
inside a browser not something you would
have really been able to do in any
reasonable way in the past but let's try
and do it right now shall we so first
we're going to have to compile this code
and i want to just move my windows
around to compile it i'm going to use
cargo build that's rust's normal build
tool chain and i've configured this
project already so that when it builds
it produces a web assembly binary so if
you look over here we've just generated
lib rust qr which targets wasn't 32
which is web assembly
okay and now we're going to want to use
that inside our.net application how can
we do it well actually rather easily
and to do that we have to first make a
reference to that library that we just
built so i'm going to go into my project
file here and you can see at the bottom
we've now got this new thing called
native file reference and i'm using it
to say i want to make available in
compilation librust qr which we just
built and then we want to call it from
our.net code so i'm going to go into a
different blazer component right now
this one is trying to render stuff into
an html canvas that's going to be the qr
code and it's going to render whatever
is inside this buffer here this byte
array and that is going to be populated
by calling generate qr code which we are
importing from that dll so there's a
bunch of things lined up together and
that will hopefully result in a call
from our.net code into rust so let's
just check that out shall we i'm going
to again rearrange my windows a little
bit like this and then i will uncomment
this line and uh press save and
hopefully because of hot reload that
call into rust will now go through and
we'll actually be rendering our qr code
and that's a real one which actually
works which is nice
okay so that's an example of how you can
make use of code written in other
languages this is also how we're using
sqlite here in the browser now
when i did a previous version of this
talk i had to show people how to compile
sql lights to webassembly
then how to add the native file
reference and how to add all of these
dll imports and different external
methods so you can call quite a lot of
work and you might think it would be
nice if we could just have someone else
do that for us
and the good news is you can so this
work can all be packaged in a nuget
package
which is exactly what has happened so if
you want to use sql lite inside your
blazer web assembly app now you can
reference
excuse me this sqlite pcl raw package
and that contains binaries of sqlite for
windows for mac for linux and as of a
couple of months ago also for
webassembly so just by referencing that
you get sqlite you can reference the f
core and that's also going to work and
and that's just how we've got sql like
that
so that's pretty nice all right next
thing
improvements to javascript interrupt we
did an improvement in dot net six which
means that when you are passing binary
data or streams
we can do it in an efficient way now
previously everything was json
serialized but as of net six if you're
working with binary data we don't go
through a serialization process it makes
it much faster and i can show you that
incredibly easily because we're doing it
already in the code that we were just
using when we call this javascript
method to populate the canvas with the
buffer we are passing this buffer here
which is a byte array
like that so prior to net six that would
have all been serialized and copied
which is not very efficient but as
of.net six whether you're using blazer
server or web assembly we can now pass
that data without serialization or
copying so that's a nice improvement
okay
now onto something a bit bigger and
perhaps more interesting i think it is
the ability to use blazer components
inside other languages and frameworks so
let's imagine that in your space agency
you're not the only division okay
there's another division besides
manufacturing called the missions team
right these people work with the people
who are actually in space performing
their missions or whatever and it's a
different group of developers that
supports that and this other group has
made some other technology choices
they've chosen to build an application
using react and i'll show you their
react application just now we won't go
through all the code but i'll just bring
it up in a browser okay so here's
missions control uh it tracks where all
the satellites are and things like you
know how long since we last saw any
aliens just typical kind of space agency
stuff like that
and it needs to talk to the same back
end so we'll have to log in uh it's
going to use the single sign-in system
so i don't have to enter my password
again but now i'm logged in i can access
all these other things to do with
missions and things like that
and one day the developers on this team
they come to you and say hey you know
while missions are happening in space
sometimes stuff goes wrong believe it or
not and we need to get replacement parts
and we need to know where the parts are
like what warehouses they're in and
stuff and we've heard that you've made
this really good inventory tracking
system we would like to have it in our
application can we do that please
so
we've already added this page for you
that just says to do please fill in your
blazer code here and make it work for us
so can we do that can we add a blazer
component into a react application well
the answer is obviously yes otherwise i
would not be raising this whole subject
that would be just making me look silly
so let's have a go at doing it shall we
let's uh move
my screen around until i can actually
see more than one thing at once
okay and we are going to have a look at
what's in there still not in the right
place there we go
right so let's go into the react code
for this equipment finder screen where
we've got the to-do
sign just there
and you can see that uh it's not doing
very much right now if you know react
you'll see this is very simple if you
don't well the only thing you need to
know is it's keeping track of some
search text which has been entered into
a box up here and then at the bottom it
just says to do so how can we bring the
blazer component in here well one way
that we could have done it historically
that's always worked is just to put a
big iframe in the page here in which we
can load a separate application and you
know that's going to work but it's kind
of rubbish because it wouldn't integrate
properly it wouldn't share any
authentication state it wouldn't share
the styling and it would be really hard
to get data into it or data back out so
wouldn't it be a lot nicer if we could
just use our blazer components as if
they were normal html elements and that
is what is now supported so if i'll show
you how we do this if i go into my
blazer web assembly startup here and
this is not a webassembly specific
feature by the way you can do this just
as well with blazer server as with
webassembly you can say
take one of the components that you've
implemented for example the inventory
and register it as a custom element with
a particular name in this case inventory
grid and then as long as you've added
the necessary script tags to your other
application you can use that just as an
html element so i'm going to add an
inventory grid right here i'll press
save and then react hot reload system
will kick in and we should now see our
blazer component show up here inside
react and it's got all the behaviors
that we expect you know it's all the
sorting and filtering it's all going to
work so that's nice
um but i don't really like the style of
it very much i don't like the fact that
it uses this light theme when everything
else uses a dark theme can we change it
well one of the nice things about the
fact that this is not an iframe it's
just normal html structure is that we
can use normal css to style it so here
inside my react application i'm going to
find the inventory grid table and i'm
going to apply a filter to say invert 1
and then
instant dark mode so that's nice that's
going to keep our astronauts a bit
happier
what else what about being able to
search so you see as i'm typing here
it's not doing anything that's because i
haven't done anything to wire the search
up
now the blazer component takes a normal
blazer parameter called search name and
i can pass that as an html attribute so
i'll press save on that and now you'll
see my search has been applied and as i
type again it's all just going to update
as i type which is pretty nice
integration there between react and net
and you may have noticed that
when i've made changes here reacts hot
reload system has been working but what
about nets hot reload system if i edit
the dot net code is that going to update
even when it's running inside react well
let's try it shall we let's go back to
the code for this inventory grid here
and i'm going to make a completely
arbitrary and otherwise pointless change
where i'm going to change the column
title you see where it says category
there well here's the code for that
let's just change it to cat name and
then i'm going to press save and when i
do so we should see inside the react
application that category name should
all be well but apparently oh there we
go
thing's a bit slow today but it did
indeed update so we've got reacts hot
reload system and blazer's hot reload
system working together in the same
application simultaneously making you
pretty productive and able to share your
code really well
all right so that's enough of the dot
net six features
let's now turn our attention to what's
going to be happening in the future or
in the very near future
and the next major way in which you'll
be able to use your blazer components
with a wider range of technologies
is the ability to take them beyond web
browsers and into native applications so
that is a feature that is going to ship
in the way now-ish like we're in q2 2022
already and this uh project.net maui is
poised to ship incredibly soon and one
of the cool things we can do with that
is use blazer with it so you might know
what maui is already but just in case
you don't very quick overview it stands
for multi-platform app ui and it is a
system by which you can build and deploy
cross-platform native view application
ui applications with net from a single
code base and target windows ios android
and mac it is
behind the scenes a major evolution of
what used to be called xamarin forms
we've done tons of work to make it into
a really first-class part of.net now
which is why it's been granted a whole
new name and it's got a lot more people
working on it and it's got a lot more
investment
so that's all very nice but what's
really nice if you're a blazer developer
is that one of the things you can do
with maui is you can do a blazer inside
it and the point of doing that is you
can now reuse the same components that
you ship for the web inside native
applications across all of these
platforms and of course you can still
make use of the native functionality
within each of those platforms so let me
give you a quick example of doing that
we'll go back into our solution here and
we'll imagine that for whatever business
need we want to make our inventory
tracking system into a native app for
example so that the warehouse workers
can walk around with it on ipads or
whatever else i don't know
and we want to share our existing code
from the web with this native
application so what's the best way of
sharing code well one way that i think
works particularly well is to just
factor it all out into a reusable
library and that's what we're doing here
so you'll notice i've got this
manufacturing hub project here and that
is the blazer webassembly application
but it contains almost no implementation
at all because the implementation for
all those components and even all the
static content that we're using is
inside this separate class library which
i've called manufacturing hub core and
the fact that it's in this separate
library means we can easily import that
and use it inside a maui project if we
want and in fact i've got a maui project
down here the one that's called native
app just going to set as startup there
now if you haven't seen maui before it's
it's a nice single project system that
targets many platforms from a single
project and you can configure various
things for each of the targeted
platforms from that one project and then
you can define the native ui for it
using xaml so it's a special flavor of
xaml that's specific to maui and one of
the things you can do inside that maui
zaml is to have a blazer webview and
this is how we can introduce our blazer
components into our native app you just
have to say which laser component you
want to render and you could render an
individual component on a fine-grained
basis or you can just literally dump
your entire application right in there
and that's what i'm doing right now i've
taken the root component for the whole
application and just put it inside a
maui window so let's start that up shall
we
so i'm going to start running it
initially on windows and this is going
to use the latest win ui 3 technology so
it can do a lot of modern windows things
and when that pops up we should see that
it looks and behaves more or less the
same as what we had before
my machine is being abnormally slow
right now but here it comes
slowly there we go all right so it's the
same thing that we had before but now
inside a native window and it's going to
have all the same behaviors and
functionality that we've seen all along
which is all very good
what you need to make sure that you
understand here though is that this is
not using webassembly okay this is not
blazer webassembly it's not blazer
server either it's a new hosting model
for blazer which is running directly on
the native.net code inside this
application and rendering it into a web
view so that's nice
now i know some of you are probably
thinking
so what like we've been able to do this
for years already like have you heard of
electron it's a way of rendering web ui
inside a native frame and that is
absolutely true so in many ways that is
similar to what electron does but
there's two main ways that maui goes
beyond what is possible with electron
one of them is that it targets a wider
range of platforms such as mobile as
well as desktop but the other perhaps
more important way is that it allows you
to use whatever combination of web and
native ui that you want so in electron
you're basically just using web ui with
some small exceptions but with maui you
can have as much native ui as you want
to give you an example of that let's
imagine that we don't want to have this
web-based navigation system up here but
instead we want to have some native
navigation that matches the look and
feel of each platform that it runs on we
can do that pretty easily so i'm going
to go back into my code here
and i'm going to say instead of this
content page right here i'm going to
replace that with a tabbed page
containing a content page and inside
that
i'm just going to put the dashboard okay
so we'll have a bit of native ui now
that oh
i don't have hot reload for maui in this
build of vs that i'm using here
i think the next preview may well have
it but this build does not so i have to
manually restart and when that comes up
you'll see we now
know what did i do i must have killed it
all right so when that comes back up we
will have our native navigation ui with
our blazer rendered dashboard inside it
there it is okay good right so we've got
our dashboard rendered inside this tab
here let's add some other native tabs
for different parts of our application
i'm going to drop in some more content
pages there's a bit of repetition here
you could factor that out if you want
but each one of these is rendering a
different blazer root component so now
we will hopefully have a complete and
working uh native navigation system so
where's my application
there is
all right so now we've got these four
tabs and you can see that they behave in
a nice sort of windows manner
and they look like windows tabs because
they are native windows tabs and
everything behaves as it should
and if we deploy this to other platforms
it's going to match the look and feel of
those other platforms to show you that
let me show you what this thing looks
like if we run it on android so i've got
an android emulator down here which i'm
going to start up
takes a moment to wake up and when that
does wake up we should see that the web
rendered ui looks exactly the same
on this platform as it does on any other
platform but the native ui matches the
look and feel for android okay so i can
switch over onto this inventory tab and
that works um but you can see it looks
different it looks android and it also
behaves android like it does this sort
of sliding thing as you move around
which i'm not sure that i like very much
but you know it does do that because
that's the way of things on this
platform so that's cool
all right and of course we can deploy to
other platforms as well such as ios and
macos and i don't actually have a mac
here to show you that but i did
pre-record a video of the same
application running on an ipad and on an
iphone and you can see that once again
the web rendered ui looks exactly the
same because why wouldn't it and the
native ui matches the style of the
platform so on ios you'll see the tabs
show up at the bottom that's just the
way things are on ios
so that's all very nice
now before we move on i want to just
pause for a moment and make sure that
i'm giving you a realistic expectation
of the degree of difficulty and power
involved in this because i'm slightly
worried that i'm making it look as if
like everything just works everywhere
and it's effortless and you become a god
well that's
you know kind of the true ish but
actually there are lots of difficulties
along the way with doing this and i want
to be realistic about that so each time
you come to deploying a new platform you
will find platforms specific differences
and challenges when i tried to deploy
this to android at first i was getting
some weird errors which turned out to be
because it was trying to store the
sqlite database in a place that android
does not allow so i had to debug and fix
that and when i deployed to ios i got a
number of weird styling issues which i
actually haven't fixed so you can see
them up here and one thing you might
notice when it goes onto the grid and it
starts scrolling it upwards is that some
text will weirdly appear at the top of
the screen on the status bar which
you'll be able to see about now yeah
well that's because the status bar is
translucent and i need to fix that
you'll also notice that on iphone there
should be some icons on those tabs and i
haven't put any icons there that's
because i developed it for windows and i
didn't know that there should be icons
so i didn't put any there so my point
that i'm making to you is not that this
is terrible or anything it's just that
you need to have the expectation that
you will have to test on each platform
and you will find some issues that make
sense among other issues that don't make
sense but nonetheless you know you will
be able to get through it
once you've done all that the payoff
from this is that you can use your
blazer components with an incredibly
wide range of technologies
so we've just seen that you can use them
on a windows native application a mac on
ios on android and of course you can
still use them on web as you've always
been able to whether you're running
inside the browser on webassembly or on
blazer server
but
that's not all there's even more
because we know that people still have
yet more types of applications than this
particularly applications that have been
around for a little while so as part of
the same release we are also adding
support for running your same blazer
components on windows forms and wpf
applications which might be a really
nice way for you to modernize existing
software properties so to give you an
example of that
let's imagine that yet again there is
another department within your space
agency besides the missions and the
manufacturing groups there's also the
accountants and you want to keep the
accountants happy because they control
whether you get paid or not and they've
got an application which in this case is
written in wpf all right so maybe it's a
legacy application maybe not i don't
know wpf is still a technology you can
use and if you know wpf you'll know that
it also uses xaml as its programming
language and inside one of my xaml files
here you'll see i'm using blazer webview
so just in the same way that you can use
blazer webview inside maui you can also
use it inside wpf and there's
equivalently a windows forms control so
you can use it there as well so that's
pretty cool let's see this working shall
we and we'll see whether the accountants
will be able to keep track of what's in
stock in all the different warehouses so
they can bill people for it or whatever
so when that comes up it's going to do
all this boring accounting stuff and we
go over onto the inventory screen and
then yet again we should see the same
application that we've been building oh
it makes me log in because it's trying
to synchronize stuff with the back end
even though there's no changes so that
doesn't help us but anyway i've done
that and that really is the same code
that we've just been working on you can
see it's got the cat name thing just
there because you know that's the latest
version of that code and it's going to
have again all the same behaviors as
before
one slightly interesting thing to point
out at this point though a little bit of
a puzzle for you if i go into this
pentagonal stub whatever that is
you'll see that it's got a qr code
rendered there now that if you think
about it might be a bit of a surprise
because we compiled that library to
webassembly and this is not a
webassembly application this is a native
windows application and there is no web
assembly in this at all so how is that
qr code showing up
well the answer is that i was being
slightly devious and secretive before
because when i said that i compiled it
to webassembly i was also compiling a
native windows binary for the same
library in the background and then the
fact that we load it using this um
what's it called
dll import well that's the same syntax
that dot net has always used for loading
native code from dlls so if there's a
native windows binary for this it will
get loaded and run inside our windows
application and similarly you could
compile a native binary for android ios
and so on if you wanted to so you can
continue to share all these parts of
your code across all platforms
so that's pretty nice all right now
let's take another step forwards in time
to where we're going to go with blazer
next and the next major release for
blazer is going to be part of the net 7
release which is scheduled for november
this year which should not be a surprise
to anyone since we do major releases of
net in november every year
and again we've got quite a lot of plans
for how we can improve blazer in dot net
7. i won't actually be able to
demonstrate them to you however because
we haven't implemented these yet we've
been so focused on maui but we are
starting and have started in pretty much
the last week on really focusing on this
part of the product now so to give you a
quick overview of what we've got uh as
candidate features on the roadmap um i
have actually kind of shown this thing
to you already when we added the
inventory grid to the react application
98 of what i was using there is stuff
that is shipped in dot net six but one
tiny bit of it is actually not shipped
yet and that will be included in net7
for custom elements we are looking at
adding multi-threading to the
webassembly runtime because modern
browsers now have the ability to do
multi-threaded web assembly code so we
want to bring that to blazer as well
we've got lots of plans to improve the
uh the performance the reliability and
the feature set inside the razer editor
so you can be looking out for some cool
new stuff going on there one thing that
i think a lot of people will like and i
certainly will like is the ability to
create a blazer project that does not
include a counter and a silly weather
forecast page um so yeah that's
definitely going to be a popular one and
very cheap for us to do
hot reload like i said before it doesn't
support every possible type of code edit
today but we're going to increase the
range of code changes that are supported
currently it's not supported to have
multiple blazer applications in the same
web page at once but we are looking at
adding that because we've got some
important customers that have told us
that they need that feature
we are considering adding a basic grid
into the box as well so you saw that
grid that i was using with blaze orbital
there well
of course there are many grids that are
already available for blazer whether
it's open source or third-party
component vendor type things and we're
not trying to replace those but we are
considering adding a very basic
lightweight and highly performant
starting point for grids inside the box
so that people can build their own stuff
on top of that
that one's too boring to talk about web
crypto um so when you do crypto at the
moment with blazer webassembly um
there's quite a lot of.net code that
gets run we're looking at mapping all
that into javascript so that it can use
the browser's built-in native crypto
features and we're also looking at
improving aot support so that instead of
aot compiling everything in your
application you can selectively compile
just the individual bits that need the
most performance gains uh so that you
don't have to wait for the
pre-compilation process for everything
else and to keep your app size small
so uh like i said it's not implemented
yet if you go to the url at the bottom
there the road map then we would love to
have your upvotes or your downvotes or
your snarky comments or whatever else
you've got to say about these features
and you can influence the process
of what we actually build over the next
few months
right but let's move on from that and
talk about something a little bit more
futuristic
about ways of taking.net into whole new
places and working with entirely new
kinds of technology okay this is not
about blazer it is about web assembly
but it's actually about web assembly on
the server and to understand why that's
relevant what that even means and why
you would want to do it we'll take a
quick step back to understand what web
assembly itself actually is so even if
you've been using this you might not
have a completely clear mental picture
of what web assembly actually is well
it's been around for about seven years
now it's quite a well-established
technology and what it actually is is a
byte code format a way of representing
instructions that are independent of any
particular operating system or cpu
architecture and it's designed first and
foremost to work inside a sandbox
because of course it's originally
designed to work in browsers where you
often face hostile code so that sandbox
needs to be incredibly rigorous and
bulletproof and trustworthy and that's
what webassembly always has been like we
don't see sandbox box escapes
with webassembly now in order to make it
that robust it's got a very minimal
feature set the only thing that web
assembly bytecode can do natively is
just perform operations on its own
memory just changes numbers in its own
memory space which might seem entirely
pointless and it would be if there was
no way of interacting with the outside
world and so the way of interacting is
by importing and exporting functions the
host such as the browser can supply
functions into the webassembly code that
it can execute and web assembly code can
export functions that the host can call
so that's how that interrupt with the
outside world actually works
now imagine you want to use this as a
server-side technology we'll talk about
why in a minute but just imagine you do
you're going to want to interact with
operating system features somehow and to
do that the best way to model it would
be by importing some functions for those
operating system features but what
functions what would the import and
could there be some kind of standard to
say what it looks like well that is what
wazi is wazi webassembly system
interface is a spec that's been around
for a few years now from mozilla and it
defines a standard set of imports of
operating system like functions so if
you want to work with a file system or
open a network socket or whatever wazi
has functions that's best well it's got
a definition for the functions you can
use
now it's still designed to be run in a
regret rigorously sandboxed way so just
because there are some functions for
working with file system for example
doesn't mean that you're allowed to use
them the host chooses what functions to
give you access to which is how it can
protect itself
and like i've been saying this is not
about running in a browser this is not
about using any kind of javascript based
runtime it's about running in a very
lightweight and contained server-side
environment
but what's the point
you can already run server-side code you
don't need webassembly to do that why
would you want to use webassembly on the
server well
there are many ways you can think about
this and people describe it in different
ways but one way that i think is useful
to think of it is that wazi can act as a
universal application binary interface
well that is a contract between a host
and some code that runs in that host and
this host it could be a cloud service it
could be something that runs at the edge
of the cloud like a cdn uh or some kind
of
low-powered iot device it could be a
plug-in model for some software like say
an office plug-in or it could be a
flight simulator or music studio plug-in
or something like that or maybe a
programmable feature of your operating
system and then the code that you're
running in there is obviously just
whatever code you the developer choose
to implement and the benefits of having
wazi be the abi well there are benefits
on both sides of the equation for
example on the host side it means that
the code that is being executed is
sandboxed which is great if that code
turns out to be malicious but more
likely the code is not malicious but it
just accidentally contains some kind of
security vulnerability well the fact
that it's sandbox means the host is
still defended even against
unintentional vulnerabilities like that
and it means the host can choose exactly
what capabilities it offers to the code
can it access fast system can it access
network things like that and even beyond
that it can decide how much cpu time is
a given call allowed to take up how much
memory are you allowed to allocate so
the host can very very uh completely
defend itself against whatever type of
code is running inside it and there are
other benefits too such as the ability
to simplify the developer experience you
can work with any build tool chain you
just have to take a single wasm file for
deployment so that's nice and then on
the application side benefits include
that you can use any programming
language as long as it compiles to
webassembly which is you know most of
them these days
and then when you come to deploy you
don't have to care what the operating
system is that you're deploying to or
even what cpu architecture it is because
the same binary will work universally
across all operating systems and all cpu
architectures
and by the nature of webassembly which
has always been about jit compiling to
nearly native speed code at runtime you
should be able to get excellent
performance
so in a way this could look like a major
evolution of containerization on the
server and some people have said that
this will be the future of server cloud
native containerization and we don't
know whether that's true maybe it is
true maybe wazi is going to take over
the industry maybe it's not we don't
know but what we do know at least what
we what we goal is on the net team is
that we are going to try and keep you at
the forefront of wherever the industry
goes so if wazi takes over the industry
net is going to be able to go there and
you as dot-net developers are going to
find that your skills and your existing
code can move to wherever the industry
goes that's our objective with what
we're doing around wazi right now so
let's think about running.net in one of
these kind of environments how do you
compile to it well you might think well
we can already compile our net code in
such a way that it runs on webassembly
that's plays a web assembly have you
heard of it and the truth is yes of
course you can do that but unfortunately
that is not going to work in a was the
environment okay the existing tool chain
will not work and to understand why
let's talk about what it does so the
tool chain we use for compiling blazer
web assembly it's called unscripten it's
been around for a while and it's
designed for running code inside a
browser so when you compile your project
what comes out of the compilation
process is
well the net runtime which is
pre-compiled to a webassembly binary and
we've already compiled that for you
obviously you also get all your net dlls
produced by the c-sharp compiler in the
normal way for your code and anything
else that you rely on and then finally
you get some javascript which knows how
to start this stuff up inside a browser
and then when your code is running when
you use some kind of call to an os
feature that eventually translates into
a call into javascript and that's what
script gives us it's this mapping of
features into javascript
so that's great when you're in a browser
it's good that we split stuff up into
lots of files because the download can
be parallelized and it's good that we're
using javascript because you know that's
what's in a browser so that makes sense
but in a wazzy environment this is not
good at all it's not good that we split
stuff up into lots of files because
that's really inconvenient to deploy and
sometimes it's actually impossible
because some wazi environments only
allow you to give them a single wasn't
file and it's certainly not good that
we're running on javascript because
there is no javascript so it's obviously
not going to work
which is why we started a new experiment
with a new way to compile.net to
webassembly using the wazi tool chain
which is built on llvm and when you use
this the output from the compilation
process is just a single webassembly
file which contains everything that you
need it's the relevant parts of the net
runtime it's your
net code and it's any other files that
you rely on all in that one file and
when you call os features it's not going
to use javascript it's going to use the
system interface functions defined by
wazzy so it can run anywhere
so let me show you this experimental new
compilation mechanism
i'll go into a command prompt and we're
going to start by making the simplest
thing we possibly can so the simplest
thing that i know of that exists in the
universe is a console project okay and
we're going to go in there cd hello wazi
and i'll just.net run that now obviously
this is not webassembly yet this is just
plain.net that we know and love and it
just prints out hello world in fact to
get a bit more info let's make it print
out slightly more stuff so i'm going to
just copy a bit of code that i've
already prepared
and we are now going to make it display
the current time in utc and the
architecture of the cpu that i'm running
on okay so go back and i'll dotnet run
that again and now it's going to display
slightly different output here's the
time in utc and here is the architecture
of the cpu in this laptop cool but how
can we run it on webassembly well we can
use this experimental new sdk called was
the sdk it's on nougat you can try it
out yourself if you want to and when
you've got that next time you do a build
you still have to be able to type sadly
then
some slightly different stuff will
happen so
let's see so it still compiles uh
your.net code to
a.net dll in the normal way but that
won't actually be used at runtime what
is used at runtime is the result from
bundling all these dlls that we depend
on and the relevant parts of the dotnet
runtime into a single wasm binary
which will pop up here hello
so that is now the whole application in
fact i'm going to just show you if i
build that another time it will go
through a bit faster because it doesn't
have to do that bundling process every
time so it's you know nice and fast and
incremental
okay so here's our file that we
generated how can we run it well there
are various server side webassembly
runners available which support yz and
the one i'm going to start with is one
called wasmtime it's an open source
project it's built by the bike herd
alliance which is a group of companies
that includes microsoft google and some
others so this is a well-engineered
runtime designed to run your webassembly
on the server and i can use it with this
binary that we just built so actually
it's called wasm time
and when i run that you'll see exactly
the same output that we had before
except now the cpu architecture as far
as it's concerned is webassembly
and that is a big step forwards um but
what's actually going on inside here
what is in this file and how do we know
if it's really compliant with the wazi
spec well let me show you if i have a
look what's inside that file i'm going
to list all the imports remember i said
that webassembly imports and exports
functions well let's see what functions
are being imported by that file you'll
see there's 23 functions that are
imported and it's stuff to do with you
know file system access and clock and
other stuff you don't need to read the
list all you need to notice is that
every single thing in that list is part
of the wazi snapshot preview 1 namespace
so these are all wazi standard compliant
functions we don't use anything that's
not wazzy which means that we can run in
anywayz environment and just to check
that let's try a different runtime this
one's called wasma it's built by a
different third-party group it's also
open source and if i
try to run the same binary in there
you'll see again it runs produces
exactly the same kind of output and you
should expect that because this is all
standards compliant stuff so that's nice
but we haven't done very much so far all
we've done is just printed hello world
to a console if you're going to work
with these technologies you probably are
trying to build some kind of new
network-enabled software because after
all this is the you know future of the
cloud and that's what people are saying
so can we build some kind of cloud
service in.net and run it in a way
environment well that would probably if
you're a net developer mean running
asp.net core on top of webassembly can
we do that
well let's check in a different example
so i've got a very very simple asp.net
core application here just about the
simplest thing we can possibly do for
every single request it's just going to
reply hello this is your operating
system architecture which really means
cpu architecture don't know why it's
called that and it says completely
standard asp.net core stuff except for
that this extension method up here this
means i don't want to use the normal
windows or linux network apis i want to
use the network apis that are provided
by wazi and as for where that comes from
well that comes from this package was
the asp.net core server native which is
part of this experimental group of sdk
packages which i've added
obviously i've also added the wazi sdk
because i want this thing to build to a
webassembly file and i've also added a
few parameters that tell the host which
tcp ports i want it to be allowed to
listen on so this is set up to just
build with net run or f5 control f5 so
i'm going to do a control f5 right now
and when that pops up you should see
that that comes up in a browser and we
do indeed get the message from asp.net
core which is now actually running on
webassembly and if we look at the native
binary that's running there you'll see
the actual native executable here is
wasm time that we are running inside so
that's pretty good but
it's still boring isn't it this is still
just the web equivalent of printing
hello world to console can we do
something a bit more interesting please
can we use some of the more advanced
features of asp.net core inside this
kind of environment
well to prove that we can i've got yet
another project over here uh this is
called asp.net core features and this is
basically what you get when you create a
new asp.net core application except that
i've also added a few extra things into
it and this is also set to compile to
webassembly and run on wasm time uh just
so that we can verify that these other
features actually work so i'm starting
that up now and you'll see again this is
running inside wazon time right there
all the console output is coming out in
the way you'd expect and in the browser
we are now doing very normal asp.net
core stuff so we execute an mvc
controller it's rendering rendering of
razer view we've also got an example
showing that razer pages is going to
work there with some static content
inside it we've also got an example of a
minimal api which just tells you what
the time is
if you want to see the code for that
well very simple stuff here's the
minimal api right there
so it's just normal asp.net core stuff
we've also got grpc in there now i don't
know if you've seen grpc running on wazi
before i hadn't before i did this but it
was extremely simple to just uh enable
because all the existing code still
worked so if i want to call this greeter
service here
which you know this is the kind of the
classic example of grpc that just
replies hello to each call that comes in
if i want to call it i'm going to need
some external code that can call make a
grpc call so i've got this command
command line application over here
called greeter client which i will run
and you'll see it does the grpc call
there which hits this endpoint inside
asp.net core which in turn is running on
a wazi runner
and that works that's nice and then
finally we've got an example of doing
signalr and websockets which again is
not something that i'd seen working on
these technologies before but the
existing.net code just works so the
normal way that we develop we do an
example of something like this is we
have two windows and let's type
something in hey there you are
and then we hit send and you'll see that
the same message shows up in both
browser windows because they're both
connected to the same web socket on
point so the point of this really is
that existing code and existing patterns
can continue to work
now in another sense that's also not the
point because if you just want to write
the same kind of applications that you
already do you don't really need wazi to
help you with that the point of this is
to be able to run your code in new kinds
of places and maybe to explore some new
kinds of application architectures and
i'm going to show you example of that in
five minutes or something but just
before we get to that i want to show you
a really bizarre example of something
that you absolutely should not do and
should never want to do and you didn't
hear it from me okay but i just think
find this kind of amusing so i want to
show it to you anyway even though it's
terrible
right so i've got another example
application over here
and if i go in there it's a boring like
to-do list type thing we've all seen
to-do list applications but the
important point is this is not blazer
it's not any kind of javascript
framework all of the ui here is going to
be just traditional server rendering so
the server renders some html and then
the browser is going to do a form
postback in order to modify the state of
the application so traditional server
ended application where can we run a
traditional server-rendered application
can we run it for example on github
pages
well the answer to that would
traditionally be no of course you can't
run it on github pages that's just a
static file server you can't do
server-rendered content there
let's see about that shall we so i'm
going to get the url for something that
i've already deployed
i'm going to go in my browser and you'll
see that this
very much is on github pages it's a real
url you can go to it in your phone or
whatever if you want to and when i go to
this url you'll see it says starting asp
net core server up and then after moment
our actual application renders on github
pages and we can go in and we can start
doing stuff do stuff like that and we
can you know start mutating the state of
the server we can have multiple browser
tabs if we want to and they're all going
to share state so you see the do stuff
shows up there we can go to this json
api and that's also got the same thing
in so how is this happening what is the
dark magic behind this well if you can
read fairly quickly you might have seen
it already the magic trick is that this
is not running on the server this is
running inside the browser and to really
prove that if i go into the browser
console here you'll see all the asp.net
core
console output is just getting spewed
out into the browser there
so it actually works
now this is of course a terrible thing
to do because it gives up on most of the
benefits of server side programming but
it is possible and i'm only showing you
just to to give you a sense of the kind
of power and flexibility we get now
we've got this tool chain for compiling
asp.net core into a single standard
compliant webassembly binary and you
know something that's famous for running
webassembly is of course browsers so
that is how we can now run asp.net call
the server inside your browser if you
want to which you don't okay now
just in case you were confused about how
this actually handles the network
requests and so on what i was doing
there when you go to this url it
registers a service worker and the
asp.net core application is running
inside that service worker in the
browser so whenever there's any tab that
tries to make an http request to
anything within that part of the url
space it gets intercepted by the service
worker which then pushes the whole
request through the asp.net core
pipeline which is you know there in
webassembly and then just gives the html
back to the browser so it never even
hits the network at all which is why it
doesn't matter whether we're on get up
pages or anywhere else we just have to
be able to serve this webassembly file
in the first place and if you've got
multiple tabs they'll be talking to the
same service worker which is how they're
able to share state within your browser
but they will not be sharing the state
with your neighbor's browser
so that's how that works okay so if
that's an example of something that you
shouldn't do you're probably wondering
well what is an example of something
that i should do then what are the real
use cases for this sort of thing
and to give you examples of that um i'll
well i will list some examples there's a
lot of industry momentum at the moment
around wazi you'll see a lot of open
source projects a lot of startups that
are trying to carve out their space
within this exciting new wazi world and
i think you'll probably see a lot more
noise around that over the next year or
two some examples of existing things
there's a startup called suborbital and
they've got a
multiple number of open source projects
that are designed for running things uh
around wazi and i'm going to show you an
example of that in a minute so we'll
come back to that wasm cloud is another
open source project this is trying to do
something a bit like kubernetes but
instead of having a collection of docker
containers you have a cluster of wazi
compliant modules that are running there
so that is potentially a lot more
lightweight than the traditional
kubernetes experience
there's also envoy this is the proxy
which is often used in service mesh
architectures often it's used with
kubernetes and envoy has got a plug-in
mechanism which allows you to supply
webassembly code so now it's possible to
run asp.net core inside envoy if you
want to and we actually do have some use
cases for doing that so that's nice
fermion another startup that are
building a bunch of open source projects
about that probably best if you just go
to their website if you want to learn
more about what they're actually
offering lunatic is an attempt to
recreate something a bit like the erlang
beam virtual machine so it's an actor
model system and this allows you
instead of just deploying a single
webassembly module instance to run your
application you will have tens hundreds
or hundreds of thousands of instances
all working together
implementing tiny bits of your
application which is designed to give
you incredible levels of scale and
reliability and then finally we must not
forget of course lest we be fired
microsoft azure now supports uh
webassembly workloads as part of the
azure kubernetes service and and you may
well see more from azure on this subject
in the future
so just to finish this off i want to
show you one of suborbital's things and
how we can work with it so volvo
volbetal has got a runner for
webassembly called sat and sat is meant
to be the most tiny lightweight and fast
way of running your webassembly code
it's designed to run on say like low
power devices or inside a cdn or that
kind of thing and i want to show you
that asp.net core can run inside there
as well now this is not a visually
spectacular demo it may seem in fact
that nothing interesting happens at all
and you'll wonder why i included it but
it's because i really want you to see
that the end-to-end picture actually
does work so i've got an asp.net core
application here it's just got these two
end points uh one is for storing a value
with a particular key and the other is
for retrieving the value
and what this is going to do is run
inside sat but more importantly it makes
use of the specific services that sat
offers so sat doesn't just run
webassembly it also gives you services
like key value storage graphql querying
or other things that you would use to
build a real application and i just want
to show you that we can in fact
integrate with all that so if i start
this running now then when that comes up
that should not be running inside wasn't
time it should be running inside sat you
can see that right there okay and i can
now make http requests into that as long
as i've got my ready-made command
all right so i'm going to use curl and
i'm going to say we'll make a request
with event name as the key and the value
as
ndc london london okay so we get a 200
okay that's coming back from our asp.net
core code and then i can do the same
request a second time this time with
just the key and you'll see the value
comes back as ndc london so just as i
promised it's not spectacular at all but
it does go to show that by being
compliant with all these standards your
existing asp.net core code can run in an
entirely new type of runner which runs
on different kinds of devices and you
can integrate with the services that it
provides so
that's all we're going to have time to
talk about today um
if you want to try out any of this stuff
it would be really great i would love it
if you would give your feedback so if
you want to try out the blaze orbital
app that we were using in a lot of these
demos you can find the source code for
that at this url and if you want to get
started with net on wazi you can go to
this url and that's where the actual sdk
is implemented but more importantly it
is also where you'll find instructions
for how to start yourself now i must
caution you
with great emphasis
that this is not a committed product the
dot net unwisely thing this is just an
experiment we're simply getting started
seeing where the industry goes seeing
what customers tell us seeing what kind
of feedback we get so i would love your
feedback about anything to do with net
on wazi what you've tried
but other than that i think we've run
out of time so
thank you for coming and i hope you have
a really lovely rest of day remember to
evaluate as you go out and um yeah
that's all so thank you